an international search is underway for
donors with an extremely rare blood type
to help save a two-year-old Florida girl
battling aggressive cancer
Zainab Mughal was diagnosed with
neuroblastoma two months ago she has one
of the rarest blood types in the world
to fight her cancer she'll need a team
of doctors and at least seven donors
Niki batiste shows us the desperate
effort to find a match Niki good morning
good morning more than 1,000 donors have
been tested so far but only three
matches have been found
Zainab parents say her family members
are not a match and they are now all
pleading with people from around the
globe to donate blood whether it's
dancing or coloring Zainab Moo called
loves to have fun like most year olds
but three months ago her parents Rahil
and Maryam noticed something was wrong
why I said you know what I feel there's
something in the stomach and we should
go to the hospital doctors found an
aggressive form of cancer called
neuroblastoma and discovered Zainab
would need life-saving blood
transfusions I was just crying all the
time and what were they what happened to
my daughter and she is happy baby like
how could be this thing happening to her
Zainab is missing a common antigen most
people carry in their blood type called
Indian be the only people that can be a
match for her blood type are people of
100-percent Pakistani Indian or Iranian
descent but even within those
populations less than 4 percent are
missing the Indian B antigen
yesterday Zainab and her parents met
with a florida-based team from the
organization one blood who are leading
the search for donors the team has been
working around the clock and so far has
found a match in London and two in the
United States that won't be enough for
Zainab's treatments but her parents say
she is a fighter she is getting better
that's why we are getting better and we
are hoping every day and have very
strong faith she will make here so far
about 11,000 people have contacted one
blood saying they meet the criteria and
want to donate Zainab's parents are
asking people to give blood even if they
are not a match because it could help
others if you would like to donate or
find out if you are a match visit our
website at CBS this morning calm bianna
hopefully more people will be reaching
out after watching that Nikki thank you